[Música]
y como lo anunciábamos previamente
iniciamos nuestra sección deportiva hoy
nos acompaña nuestro periodista Luis
Méndez y con él vamos a comenzar
hablando de golf porque todo está listo
para el Us Open de esta disciplina Luis
bienvenido y cuéntenos más al respecto
Muchas gracias a María es el tercer
medio del año y que se presente en medio
de lo que ha sido un anuncio de la pga
de suspender a golfistas que decidieron
participar la semana pasada en el Dif
Gold series un torneo financiado por
Arabia Saudita el Us Open regresa este
año a Brooklyn Massachusetts uno de los
campos de golf más antiguos de Estados
Unidos por primera vez desde
1988 y este año no contará con la
participación de Tiger woods en optó por
tomarse un descanso los mejores
jugadores de golf incluidos los peces
campeón de Clans
esperan dar lo mejor de Sí para alzar el
trofeo de uno de los torneos más
prestigiosos de esta disciplina
Precisamente en medio de la algarabía
del US Open de golf y la final de la NBA
entre Golden State y Boston el trofeo
fue llevado al City Garden de la Ciudad
de Boston donde fue admirado por el
jugador de golden State Steve curry un
amante del Golfo pero el torneo se
presenta en medio de la polémica que
surgió a raíz de la aparición de la Live
con Siri es un torneo financiado por
Arabia Saudita que ha sido cuestionado
por muchos tanto directivos como
jugadores por el historial de abusos
contra los Derechos Humanos que tiene la
nación sobre este tema más temprano
conversamos con Juan David Bernal
colaborador de Call Channel y marca
claro y esto fue lo que nos dio
Pues con esta particularidad de lo que
ha suscitado la League Golf no esta
serie de este Tour saudí de fondos
saudís apuesto a digamos a la gente a
discutir mucho en torno al mundo del
golf no solo Sergio García y dustin
Johnson como tú mencionas sino otros
jugadores también como film michaelson
bryson de shambó
bueno Y algunos otros que son casi 10 en
total que ya aceptaron en jugar la liga
Golf la la serie saudí que ya se jugó el
primer torneo la semana anterior en
Londres y que pues el PJ tour ha
decidido tomar medidas sanciones para
este tipo de jugadores algo particular
es que
digamos lo que han hecho la mayoría de
los jugadores ha sido renunciar al PJ
antes de que se conocieran sus sanciones
renunciaron a su estatus de miembros del
PJ tour con lo cual de alguna forma
dejaban el camino libre para los majors
estos cuatro torneos importantes que son
el máster de augusta El Us Open el PJ
championship y el open británico
Entonces digamos que en Estados Unidos
lo están llevando a a lo están escalando
a un tema más geopolítico como dicen
ellos de Sports o de preguntarse si
realmente los árabes pueden captar el
deporte de occidente los símbolos
deportivos de occidente solo con el
dinero Luis y que es jugador podría
destacarse en este torneo pero claro por
supuesto que hay varios nombres pero Los
favoritos para ganar este trofeo que
terminará el próximo día domingo son los
que ganaron anteriormente este torneo y
sobre todo por las condiciones que
presenta este campo en Massachusetts
pero sobre ello también conversamos con
nuestro invitado escuchemos que nos dijo
siempre es difícil hablar de favoritos
en el gol pero llega Por ejemplo horror
y mackley el nor Irlandés ganó la semana
pasada del abierto de Canadá digamos
llega con ese momento como número tres
del mundo
creo que puede ser uno de los de los
candidatos al torneo Justin Thomas el
norteamericano te ganó el último Major
el championship creo que también es otro
de los que está llamado a tener una
buena participación de ahí en cuanto a
los latinos Pues tú mencionaste muy bien
a mito Pereira que lamentablemente hizo
cometió muchos errores en el último hoy
en el hoyo 72 del PJ Chip y se quedó sin
la posibilidad de alcanzar ese primer
majore Yo creo que él es uno de los que
quizás pueda tener una buena actuación
Joaquín neiman sin duda alguna creo que
a mi opinión personal es el que tienen
el juego más completo es un jugador muy
sólido un jugador cover un jugador que
ha demostrado ya ganar torneos
importantes manejar bien la presión